hey this is presh talwalkar
chittich from india sent me this problem
from the 1994 india regional mathematics
olympiad
a leaf is torn from a paperback novel
the sum of the numbers on the remaining
pages is 15 000.
what are the page numbers on the torn
leaf
are there a couple notes i want to add
about this problem first a leaf means a
single sheet of paper
second the quoted problem is actual
wording from the competition
but we need to assume the book is
numbered in the usual way starting on
page one
without skipping any pages
in the original video i posted i also
over thought the problem
and i put in some assumptions that were
not there in the original wording
thankfully many of you pointed out
comments that help me correct the video
and so i can now present the correct
answer
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so what happens if we remove a leaf from
the book
let's imagine we rip this page from the
book
well this page would have a number of x
now what would be on the opposite side
of this leaf we would have another page
number say x minus one
in other words when we remove a leaf
from the book we're removing two
sequential pages pages numbered x and x
minus 1 from the book
suppose the book is numbered from 1 to n
the sum of all the pages in the book is
the sum of the numbers from 1 to n
this is the well-known formula n times n
plus 1 all divided by 2.
we know that the total sum of all the
numbers
minus the missing pages is equal to
fifteen thousand
so we can set up an equation
n times n plus one all over two
minus x minus the quantity x minus one
this equals 15 000.
now there are two unknown variables in
this equation so we're not going to be
able to solve it in a single equation
what we can do instead
is use some estimation
let's ignore the x and x minus one
so we have that n times n plus one all
over two is approximately equal to
fifteen thousand
this is because the two page numbers
will be small relative to fifteen
thousand
we can then estimate
that n times n plus one is approximately
thirty thousand
this means n squared is approximately
thirty thousand
so n is approximately the square root of
30 000
which is about 173.2
this is not a whole number value
so we're going to consider the adjacent
whole values
we'll test out n equals 173 and n equals
174.
so first let's try n is equal to 174.
in that case the sum of all the pages in
the book will be 15
225.
the two missing pages will have the sum
of 225
and we can readily solve that those will
be values of x minus 1 is equal to 112
and x is equal to 113
and originally i thought that was the
answer to this problem
but as many of you pointed out
and gary einhorn was the first comment
that i saw who pointed out this mistake
in the original video
if the first leaf is numbered one and
two
then every leaf will have the odd number
page be one less than the even page
so pages 112 and 113 are not on the same
leaf
so this could not be the answer because
112 and 113 aren't on the same physical
sheet of paper
so that leaves us to consider the other
possibility
what if n is equal to 173
now originally i wrongly excluded this
answer
i assumed that both sides of each leaf
had to be numbered so book would always
have an even number of pages
but it is possible that the last page of
a book is blank and not numbered that
doesn't contradict anything in the
original wording of the problem
and this is a pretty tricky problem and
that's why it's an olympiad problem
so what if n is equal to 173
then the sum of all the page numbers is
equal to fifteen thousand fifty-one
this means the two pages would have a
sum of fifty-one and then we can readily
solve that those two pages will be
twenty-five and twenty-six
so this is the correct answer to the
problem did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh and
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at presh talwalkar